I got to tell you about it
a story of a girl friend of mine who is
a mostly lesbian bisexual and she
usually sleeps with women that's her
thing but she also sometimes sleeps with
men and I was out for dinner with her
and I was mentioning I was going to have
this conversation with you
and she said uh well it's really
interesting thinking about the way that
coming off the pill changed and she
spoke about a lot of the stuff that I'm
sure we'll get into to do with the
changes in stress and sort of the depth
and color of her emotions and things
like that uh but then she said one other
thing that I noticed when I came off the
pill was that for one week out of every
month I was straight again
that is like that's so fascinating and I
guess I I can guess which week of the
month it was
[Laughter]
have you ever come across that before
yeah so that is something that I've
heard from I can't even begin to tell
you
um how many women I've heard that from
um I've heard from a lot of uh bisexual
women
um who uh get nudged one way or the
other depending on where they are in the
cycle
um I've I've heard from women who
thought that they were bisexual and then
went on or off the birth control pill
and then had that change where they were
either completely straight or thought
that they were completely lesbian and so
was there a did you manage to find a
significant swing in one way or the
other you know it's really interesting
because for most
um the the thing I've heard the most but
I've heard I've heard it all but the
thing I've heard most frequently is um
is that they become a little more
straight when they're off the pill
so again we're looking at the highest
rates of bisexuality ever amongst women
right now but we're also probably
looking at the highest uptake of
hormonal birth control ever so how many
of the things that we're seeing at the
moment even from men's behavior is being
influenced by the pill
I know I mean it's it's exactly I mean
exactly yes I mean the idea you know
we've
researchers have long suspected a role
of uh sex hormones like steroid sex
hormones in terms of sexual preference
right and um and and the story that you
just told and the stories I've I've
heard from women are very much
consistent with um sort of hormonal
nudges in terms of of preferences and
for some women it might just nudge them
you know right over the borderline into
bisexuality and some women it can nudge
them right over the side from being
bisexual to
um being fully uh heterosexual and some
women it nudges in the other direction
and I actually had this idea because
after I'd heard this story so many times
I started thinking about late in life
lesbians and you know there's this
tendency and and you know culturally we
tend to think about this as just being
something where women you know sort of
get tired of all the [ __ ] involved
in being involved with men and that
they're just looking for you know
companionship and that in that you know
and then they start to like they form
these
um close and even sex actual
relationships with other women
but then I started thinking about
menopause and you know the menopausal
transition is this other period of like
hormonal disruption right where you go
from a naturally cycling state where you
have this waxing and weaning of hormones
including this big surge of estrogen
that surrounds the periodulatory window
that's associated with an increased
preference for masculinity and maleness
and just like that sort of thing and all
of a sudden you know over time when our
ovarian hormones begin to really rapidly
decline estrogen levels are you know
very very low in uh in post-menopausal
women and I started thinking about
latent life lesbians and um and whether
that might also like be something that's
emerging as a result of an actual
hormonal nudge where it's sort of
nudging women out of the domain of
heterosexuality and or or bisexuality
into
um into this sort of different mate
preference State well think about it
this way let's take grandmother
hypothesis right why it is that women go
through menopause at all so that they
can contribute to the rearing of
children whilst not contributing more
children that need to be reared with one
of the explanations that you have for
why lesbian women exist at all which is
kind of like a female on female pair
bonding aloe Parenting Agreement type
scenario yeah if you combine those two
together I mean what better way for
grandmother to ensure that her and some
of the other women that she needs to
look after her children and
grandchildren are bounded together
sufficiently well that while the guys
are out hunting wildebeest or whatever
it is that they do
the women get it on a little bit you
know yeah yeah I know it's such an
interesting idea it's so interesting I
find all that so fascinating what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]